hommage enfin à goscinny le père l'un
des pères le scénariste d'astérix et
obélix disparu il ya 25 ans mais
toujours au sommet vous allez voir
marylène bono jean louis malle à deux
doigts de grenadine pas mal d'agilité au
clavier et l'imagination débordante des
quotas le regarder gossip nu sur les
gaulois balayé la bande d'aouzou mais
les années 60 la chance de faire quelque
chose qui plaît au public qui amuse le
public qui nous amuse aussi alors il n'y
a pas de raison de s'arrêter là la
position marché toujours nerveux a
continué 16-25 ans après la disparition
de son ami astérix chez les belges
ressort un album hommage c'était le
dernier signé du célèbre et quand les
avis paru en 1978 puis 68 millions
d'albums d'astérix ont été vendus dans
le monde dont 130 millions signé
goscinny uderzo un succès planétaire
d'accord d'accord goscinny est celui qui
a révolutionné la bande dessinée et ils
continuent d'influencer les nouvelles
générations des jeunes dessinateurs
jeunes auteurs qui ont beaucoup de
talent et qui est mais je suis persuadé
que le modèle de signer les a amenés à
ça parce que sans elle le signe et on en
sera encore la tarte à la crème goscinny
a travaillé avec une vingtaine de
dessinateurs gotlib maurice tabary ou
encore sempé sa mort sa fille avait 9
ans elle n'avait pas eu le droit de lire
les albums de son père j'ai pris
conscience de sa célébrité à l'article
était déjà mort puisque chez nous
tous les albums qu'il avait écrite est
enfermé dans une bibliothèque que
j'appelais la bibliothèque interdite ce
que c'était des éditions précieuse
puisque c'étaient les premières éditions
et goscinny est aussi l'inventeur
d'expression célèbre devenir calife à la
place du calife ou tirer plus vite que
son ombre
entrée dans le dictionnaire